so in the one hand you've got the sort
of top of the investment level
perspective an art that's incredibly
expensive and rather magnificent Museum
going in I was a artist in Laura side of
New York back in the day and the people
I was hanging out with of course the
Loring site because that's where it was
cheap to live and everything was on the
just getting by and so there I assumed
that square with many young ambitious
artists in Hong Kong and elsewhere and
then that overlaps into incense art his
ARS rebellion anyway you're always
rebellion against the standard art
before your rebellion against the man
who or that penis and protesters that
you know in the United States are in off
the protesters in Hong Kong right now
who seem to have more creative
techniques and more creative industry in
a way in in their protest that's pretty
interesting and bottom-up kind of
creativity what's your perspective on
that it's very interesting to watch the
the visual language that's being applied
now in in Hong Kong primarily of course
it's a tool for communication it has
nothing to do with museum per se but as
a museum we are very interested in that
as a visual culture form the protesters
use the this emblem to describe
themselves they're they talk them about
themselves as being like water so they
will flow they're free-flowing they're
leaderless they're spontaneous and so a
lot of the material
that's been that's taking place in terms
of protest it's digital and it's a
digital form as a communication tool and
and all of it is unauthorized Oh
our teams are very interested where our
documenting we have archives and so we
can document we are doing that and
researching how or when and if it enters
the collection it has to go through the
usual museum mechanism and process of
thinking and looking and seeking rights
who owns these things and perhaps they
are not to be owned and that's fine but
then it exists in other kinds of ways so
it's it's a very very interesting
phenomena this time unlike so much much
earlier periods of protest art which had
very clear activist expressions you know
like you couldn't win in the u.s. there
are the guerrilla girls and there are
whole portfolios of prints and so on
that are very clearly authored and
therefore distribution this is a very
different mechanism that that's taking
place in Hong Kong and the digital tool
is phenomenal